in trouble he's Chris  [Applause]  like he minute huh Wow he cocked that  baby giving it to the cat this whole  second hand finding Chris going to work  trying to navigate block by aniline walk  by Alan sexing has a 20 of time gotta  kick it back out  undaunted sexy dancing composure ain't  speed to burn 118 118 3,000 ounces  aboard put his hood second hair and then  take it to the young man right in there  / - beautiful job boy he just kept his  career he knew the [ __ ] a see when he  got that rebound backed it out and  spread the floor wasn't a foul before  they even elevate first shot Carol  Willick  backs it out got it oh my goodness  another overtime wow I didn't think this  would happen right there had a chance to  file but you have to give him credit for  heavenly shots like that if you're gonna  file right there who's gonna have  Russell now force the switch against  Stauskas  sights fires hit the Angelo or Russell  [Applause]